mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünschen ihnen viel vergnügen
nach einer ewig langen zwangspause geben
büne huber und patent ochsner beim
blausee im berner oberland wieder
open-air-konzerte begrenzt auf 1000
zuschauer kommt da stimmung auf
[Musik]
kulturplatz schaut sich um
wie ein open air konzert unter corona
schutz bedingungen funktioniert
[Musik]
willkommen auf dem kulturplatz wir
machen heute station am gar nicht so
blauen blausee bisher
und hier wurde eine open air bühne in
den see gebaut hier will patent ochsner
endlich wieder vollgas geben hier wollen
sie ihre mitreißende musik spielen aufs
leben an stimmen
wir werden sehen ob der funke zünden
kann trotz corona maßnahmen ob sich der
himmel scharlachrot fern wird hier über
den blausee sowie die träume von
frontmann büne huber ihn treffe ich kurz
vor konzertbeginn das beste kommt heute
[Musik]
sektor
die frage wie funktioniert das der
sektor mit vier verschiedenen sektoren
so unkompliziert zubereiten und das
etwas hiermit dadurch lange tanzen musik
lädt kanalfähre motiviertes publikum
begleitet
dabei bekommt sie das spezielle
bedingungen
[Musik]
da fließt sie dahin wie kam das
trotz allem ja der kommende herbst
könnte unter dem motto trotz allem
stehen sozialen baut also patent ochsner
hier am blausee eine freiluftbühne auf
trotz allem finden sie statt die
kulturveranstaltungen vom foto festival
in bürger bis zum filmfestival in
venedig da überall schauen wir nachher
hin
doch zuerst zu harten realität neben dem
trotz allem menschen verlieren ihre jobs
geschäfte müssen schließen staaten
verschulden sich das kümmert die digital
vault ist wie google amazon und co
wenig sie sind die großen gewinner der
krise
der französische
wirtschaftswissenschaftler gabriel sieht
man nennt das in seinem neuesten buch
den triumph der ungerechtigkeit
sie sind die großen gewinner der
pandemie die digital giganten wie
netflix amazon und co machen
milliardenumsätze während gleichzeitig
überall menschen um ihre existenz
kämpfen geschäfte schließen regierungen
und parlamente gigantische staatliche
hilfspakete schnüren um die wirtschaft
vor dem komplett absturz zu bewahren
die korona krise verschärft allerdings
nur eine ungleichheit die schon vorher
da war die großen
globalisierungsgewinner die
multinationalen firmen und ihre
aktionäre die superreichen also zahlen
seit jahren immer weniger steuern
in der gleichen zeit mussten niedriglohn
arbeiter und kleinere firmen die nicht
so sehr von der globalisierung
profitieren immer mehr steuern bezahlen
gabriel sieht man beschreibt in seinem
buch mit welchen tricks die reichsten
unternehmen der welt gewinne verschieben
um steuern zu sparen während andere
draufzahlen
für ihn ist die steuerfrage die
gerechtigkeitsfrage unserer zeit corona
macht sie noch drängender an ihr könnte
sich das schicksal unserer demokratien
entscheiden
die politik philosophin katja gentinetta
hat gabriel sieht man's buch für uns
gelesen
seine thesen hinterfragt was ich bei sub
man ganz wichtig finde wenn man sich mit
diesem buch beschäftigt ist dass er in
erster linie von den usa ausgeht und in
den usa ist tatsächlich so dass die
ungleichheit der einkommen und vermögen
in den letzten 20 jahren enorm gewachsen
ist das heißt es ist umgekehrt genauso
wichtig die schweiz davon abzugrenzen
weil gerade in der schweiz ist das nie
in diesem fall passiert
doch auch hierzulande verdienen die
globalen tech konzerne an den lokalen
nutzern steuerzahlen sie hier aber kaum
online dienstleistungen sind an keinen
ort an keinen staat gebunden
deswegen können die tech giganten ihre
gewinne einfacher als andere branchen
irgendwo verbuchen
bevorzugt in steueroasen
mit der pandemie machen sie big business
geben aber den gesellschaften fast
nichts zurück allein 2009 10 hat google
alfabet eines der größten unternehmen
der welt
20 milliarden euro gewinn steuerte auf
den bermudas verbessert das ist grotesk
und wie haben es toleriert die regierung
toleriert hat jal
aber es ist kein naturgesetz
wer noch die tech giganten profitieren
von staatlichen errungenschaften wie
universitärer forschung digitaler
infrastruktur amazon chef jeff bezos ist
in der krise um rund 57 milliarden
dollar reicher geworden
wir kommen an einen punkt an dem die
reichtums verteilung zum problem für die
demokratie werde so sieht man der
reichtum und damit die macht der
konzerne steigen während nationalstaaten
verarmen
weil ihnen das geld fehlt um die
sozialsysteme am leben zu erhalten
um die folgen der korona krise zu
lindern
das interessante an der groner krise ist
ja dass es sich um eine globale pandemie
handelt aber in erster linie
nationalstaaten darauf reagieren mussten
und das globale system ja nicht fähig
war in der erwünschten weise koordiniert
darauf zu reagieren
ich glaube schon dass diese krise
gezeigt hat dass wir diese globale
koordination verbessern müssen
und wenn es um steuern geht und wenn es
um unternehmen steuern geht dann stellt
sich schon die frage ist jetzt der
moment gekommen wo wir unternehmen und
ihre gewinne etwas globaler betrachten
müssen eine europaweite digital steuer
wäre eine lösung
amazon und co sollen dort einheitliche
steuern zahlen wo sie werbung schalten
und daten sammeln ihre geschäfte machen
also in europa und nicht wo ihr
firmensitz gemeldet ist
die sozialistische regierung spaniens
hat diese steuer beschlossen
doch sie ist längst kein linkes projekt
auch makro hat sie eingeführt
österreich hat damit in den ersten fünf
monaten dieses jahres 20 millionen euro
eingenommen
3 prozent ihrer umsätze sollen die tech
giganten bezahlen viele milliarden die
in der krise helfen würden
doch einigkeit ist nicht in sicht eu
länder wie irland und luxemburg locken
mit niedrigsteuern und blockieren
gemeinsame steuergesetze in einer
gesellschaft und gerade in einer
demokratischen gesellschaft müssten wir
schon das gefühl haben dass alle in etwa
ihrer leistungsfähigkeit angemessen
einen beitrag zu dieser gesellschaft
leisten
und das heißt aber auch umgekehrt dass
alle einen gewissen beitrag leisten
müssen und es im prinzip niemanden geben
darf der einfach nur profitiert von
gesellschaften die nicht noch ungleicher
werden wollen brauchen ein gerechtes
steuersystem inklusive digital steuer
doch die schweiz verzichtet bislang
darauf sie will lediglich eine
einprozentige abgabe von streaming
diensten zur stützung des einheimischen
film marktes
das ist gar wenig
[Musik]
eine tolle stimme im konzert mit dem
chor ohne sicherheit das frage ich jetzt
herausstellt
was haben sagt schlager vom boden
studiert was heißt für eine
veranstaltung des two sie glüht oder für
beide applaus was ich extrem eignet für
das 6 teiler und somit der druck dann
sage vom eingang her gewährleistet das
glück durch separate berge im sektor
und das bedeutet zustieg corona
maßnahmen durchsetzen
günter de lüt vier primaso liegen oder
was bedeutet das konkret
das bedeutet dass sie nicht jede freie
natur an einem schönen ort wenn sich's
leben stadthaus berührt ja stärker
sektor der helm sämtliche daten erfasst
vor den altar zu informieren das ist das
experiment das jetzt dort zu machen was
spricht dafür dass gerade jetzt machen
es spricht für youtube und zwar als
positives zeichen setzte es geht es geht
ja auch im bahnhof zürich im bahnhofs
bayern partie ist übergangslager dass
hier wieder verliebte gelungen
berücksichtigung für eine
sicherheitsmaßnahme aber das zeichen für
2008 hatte impuls gesetzt hat der bühne
holbergs zeit ich muss jetzt auf boni
oder sind sie zu dass sie das virus aber
der positiv ist dass er selber betrieben
wird und bayern
sie freue sich wahnsinnig freuen
[Musik]
trotz allem das sagt man sich auch in
wewer obwohl dort sagt man viel eher mal
korrektur jedenfalls ist dort am
wochenende das renommierte festival emaf
gestartet dann ständig an der fotografie
so wie sonst auch alle zwei jahre
obwohl so wie sonst auch ist im
schmucken städtchen am genfer see
natürlich momentan längst nicht alles
bilder erklimmen die fassaden es lockt
das kühle nass der welt während drei
wochen zum grössten schweizer
fotofestival unter freiem himmel
das motto passt zur aktuellen lage
unexpected lazar die shows zu deutsch
unerwartet wie der zufall so spielt
so ging auch der däne peter funk sein
projekt an über jahre fotografierte er
wahllos passanten hat er immer gleichen
straßenkreuzungen new york
und siehe da manche tauchen immer wieder
auf
zur gleichen tageszeit oft im gleichen
look
mit dem immer gleichen accessoire ein
liebevoller blick auf den menschen als
gewohnheitstiere
es ist eine art sozialstudie von
menschen im öffentlichen raum was sie
tun in ihrer ganz privaten momenten auf
ihrem weg von a nach b zur arbeit
es sind geschichten von täglichen
ritualen und lud ihnen wie wir sie alle
haben
funk lebt wie alle anderen ausstellenden
fotografen vom austauschen festivals
doch dieses jahr gab es viele absagen
es scheint wieder in richtung öffnung zu
gehen mit ausstellungen im öffentlichen
raum schön wieder rauszukommen leute um
sich zu haben mit ihnen zu diskutieren
tatsächlich war auch das festival in
bösel länger auf der kippe doch nun
läuft alles wie gewohnt zwar mit maske
an allen ausstellungsorten in
innenräumen aber mit großer motivation
bei den beteiligten
wähle das finale basiert und stadt
findet das irre viele seiten im test die
denen projekte was vielleicht der
letzten jahre die liga hat in den
letzten jahren spielerisch schafft sie
das ja die muslime seriös aber 2020
beispielhaft für diese ernsthaftigkeit
der franzose christian boltanski mit
seiner für wwe erneuerten raumgreifenden
installation chance von der
kunstbiennale in venedig 2011 sieht aus
wie eine zeitungs presse ist dabei eine
form von glücksrad mit fotos von
neugeborenen stoppt die maschinen rückt
ein gesicht speziell in den fokus
zufällig ausgewählt aus der masse
[Musik]
die rote zahl summiert die todesfälle
zur selben zeit geburt und tod ein
untrennbares paar
[Musik]
wir wollen den tod aus unserem alltag
verbannen
jetzt ist er wieder ganz da so wie auch
die gefahr in diesem moment wo ich mit
ihnen spreche geben sie mir vielleicht
die krankheit weiter oder ich stecke sie
ihren es herrscht eine allgemeine
verunsicherung wie ich sie nie zuvor
erfahren habe nicht einmal in der zeit
von aids als noch eine reelle gefahr
drohte war es vergleichbar so hat corona
die vorher alles beherrschende
klimafrage verdrängt dagegenhalten julia
behr materie und edoardo de lille aus
italien eigene fotos von bewohnern der
malediven überblenden sie mit frei
verfügbaren bildern von tauchern oder
meerestieren ein poetisches mahnmal für
die prognose dass die inselgruppe als
eines der ersten länder wegen der
globalen erwärmung von der weltkarte
verschwinden könnte wir schaffen gern
mehrere ebenen wie wir bilder gelesen
werden können dieses bild zeigt
vielleicht nur eine familie
man muss sich aber vorstellen ihr haus
wird ende des jahrhunderts unter wasser
stehen immer bilder gezeigt von den
auslösern der klimaveränderung die berge
von plastikmüll die luftverschmutzung
wir hingegen boten ein bild der zukunft
prägen
zurück zum diesjährigen motto zufall
eine der schönsten arbeiten in bösel ein
vogelschwarm im steigflug das bild haben
die vögel über einen bewegungssensor
selbst ausgelöst ganz ohne menschliches
zutun
[Musik]
ja und da ist das schöne tier war auf
die schweizer offiziere nach der anträge
auf bühnen auftreten ist das so aber ich
gerne sieht es aber ganz eigenartigen
köster nicht genau was es war
also es ist dass das massenpublikum nein
ich glaube wenn sie durch sind es ist
tatsache erschwere die situation wie sie
müssen ja kreuzband mich enorm in einer
noch nie da hat man mineralisiert die
forscher vor dem kontakt wo ich jetzt
irgendwo auf der aber nie vergeht wo
faust das ist schon eigenartig aus
mettmann musste damit auch bruno wir
hoffen dass das mini itx gedacht
foto klicken
wenn es irgendwie scharf sportive ball
flach wenn es die namen für das tutorial
hauptachse negative verläuft das heißt
noch nicht künstliches koma buchwald
ideen zu mit dem bad nicht gram negative
verlaufen und anstrengend ist das
vielleicht job los und du wirst nicht
zwölf stunden auf der bühne gestanden
wie es viele rollen singen
ja irgendwie sony fordern sie sagt
irgendwas was im ersten moment bin ich
sehr melancholische und sagt hatte mit
der welt tut und ein ziemlich gestoppt
worden weil ich das eben krank
vielleicht sogar steht dass sich die
schaeffler-führung neckar nach
mit der band musik zu machen weil das
ist eine der aufgaben von ihm selber
sagen
da durfte ich habe familie naja gut
gemerkt dass ihm nicht so wahnsinnig
süchtig b hofer ab bronze besichtigung
baxi und und band leider müssen wir auch
zerrüttung gewächs und das ist einfach
das geht mir unglaublich viel wissen
über das was nicht beschrieb es ist
einfach lustig und sehr intensiv mit
starker aus da sein mit der sechste
entfernt
[Musik]
aber ja der ruder egon wird zu meinem
gondoliere denn jetzt schauen wir nach
venedig nachdem man sich in lockerer und
kann weitgehend der pandemie beugen
musste will man beim filmfestival in
venedig möglichst nahtlos an die
glamourösen zeiten vor corona anknüpfen
wir schauen ob das gelingen kann mein
kollege selling peterson war vor ort
[Musik]
dollar
ups da ist doch was frauen ist das
rücklichter markusplatz
so hört man die touristen feier
eigentlich nur aus märchenhaften für den
klassikern wie don't look now mit donald
sutherland befreit vom dichter strässle
die lagunenstadt der zeit zum verweilen
ein
doch ich muss weiter denn das filmfest
steigt bekanntlich nicht hier auf der
hauptinsel sondern am 15 kilometer
entfernten lido ich habe mir sagen
lassen dass dort noch stärker darauf
geachtet wird dass sich jeder an die
masken pflicht hält aufs festivalgelände
kommt nur wer die richtige
körpertemperatur hat wobei cool zu
bleiben gar nicht so einfach ist und
einer pistole direkt vorstellen
glück gehabt also rein ins kino
vergnügen
aber was schon auf den postern stehen
vor einer kaum klingen den rahmen und
gute kritiken haben die wettbewerbsfilme
bisher auch nicht bekommen
fündig werde ich schließlich außer
konkurrenz
[Musik]
die doku heimgeräte zeigt den aufstieg
der beherzten aktivistin zur anführerin
der klimabewegung die in den letzten
monaten von corona etwas ausgebremst
wurde der pressekonferenz lobt die live
aus ihrem klassenzimmer zugeschaltete
schwedin die art und weise in der
regisseur nathan großmann sie
porträtiert hat du hast es geschafft
nicht so zu zeigen wie ich bin
statt so wie es die medien tun als
zorniges naives kind das an der
uno-generalversammlung die führer der
welt anschreit
[Musik]
das macht mich als person nicht aus die
meisten können geräte tatsächlich nur so
das ist alles falsch
es sollte nicht hier sein sondern in
meiner schule auf der anderen seite des
ozeans
trotzdem sucht ihre hoffnung bei uns
jungen wie könnt ihr es wagen regisseur
nathan großmann hier noch mit maske kurz
vor unserem interview filmte greta
bereits als sie noch niemand kannte
im gespräch erzählt mir der 29-jährige
wie alles begann
ein freund ihr gerät das familie kennt
kann den tipp sie plante sich mit einem
schild fonds schwedische
regierungsgebäude zu setzen
also bin ich dort hin und fragte sie ob
ich sie vergraben um aufzunehmen
zugleich sagte hier machte keine
hoffnungen wahrscheinlich wird nichts
draus
es kam bekanntlich anders als eine der
ersten erkannte großmann gretas
potenzial und will ich ein jahr lang
nicht mehr von ihrer seite
die verdichtung der 100 stunden der
dabei aus nächster nähe aufnahm ist
atemberaubend
dies ist erst der anfang
sogar auf dem segelboot mit dem greta
vor einem jahr den atlantik überquerte
um co2 emissionen zu verhindern war der
dokumentarfilmer mit dabei
diese boote wirken von außen sehr groß
als ich unser boot zum ersten mal sah
dachte ich das ist stattlich das passt
erst wenn man an bord geht merkt man wie
tränen dachte ich nur noch das wird ein
wilder ritt durch zu halten hat sich
gelohnt nicht nur für großmann sondern
auch für das filmfest das den roten
teppich wegen corona kurzerhand zum
maskenball umgestaltete mit ihrem
preisträgerin tilda swinton
jury-präsidentin cate blanchett und
vielen weniger bekannten gästen in den
kinos darf nur jeder zweite platz
besetzt werden
trotzdem ist alberto barbera das
festival keine halbe sache sondern ein
wichtiges signal dass venedig auch diese
krise meistern will
die viel größere bedrohung daran hat
michael graeter erinnert klappt der
klimawandel viel weiter auf der
meeresspiegel nicht mehr steigen sonst
heißt es hier endgültig land unter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
monheim
[Musik]
das ist auch das glück dass er starb
die bühne und wiegen so schön alleine
stößt und schließt christian mehr
verbucht ohne hier mitnehme
[Musik]
erster leader spielt hier am blausee und
man kann nur noch soviel sagen patent
ochsner org definitiv auch mit corona
schutzmaßnahmen die lieder treffen mit
noch bis mitte september rocken büne
huber mit seiner band der pause alles
ist restlos ausverkauft höchste zeit
also dass sich auch andere wieder zurück
auf die bühne wagen ja und wir fragen
nächste woche was ist ein held und
weshalb ich treffe dann einen
schriftsteller der von sich behauptet
ein superheld zu sein jetzt gleich vor
der report der magd ich geld zurück ins
konzert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]